よろしくお願いします
残りはそんなに難しくはない同じことの繰り返しだと思いますけど
では今日は何番目ですかね
キッワマヌセカヨガディッバンヨガムパッジャガサッバヨガウィサンユッタントタマハンブルーミブラフマナン
ヒッワマヌセカヨガディッバンヨガムパッジャガサッバヨガウィサンユッタントタマハンブルーミブラフマナン
で この偈ではこの阿羅漢になった人の心の状況を説明しているんですけど
このその場合はこの使っている言葉はヨーガという言葉なんですね
ヨーガっていうのは関わりという意味なんですね
関わりがあるという ただ一言葉で阿羅漢という状況を説明できるんですよ
ですから この場合はただ関わりという一言葉を使っているんですね
それでヒッワマヌセカヨガ
まあ人間の世界に関する関わりは
だからマヌセカというのは人間に関する関わり
全部ヒッワ もうない もう関わりは心にはないということで
それからディッバンヨーガ
ディッバンというのは人間より乗り越えている天ということなんですね
まあ人間のことに何も関わりも何も未練もないだけではなくて
人間を超えている神々
天国とか天とかね そういうところに対しても
別に何も未練も何も関わりもないという
そういうことでサッバヨーガウィサンユッタン
心にこの関わりたいという関係持ちたいと
何かの関係を持ちたい
何持ちたい 何かの関わりを持ちたいという
あるいは関わりを持っているという
それがないんですね だからその都度その都度
あの まあやることはやってるかもしれませんけども
人々いますよ ものすごくもうあの人と関わり持ちたい
この人と関わりを持ちたい
もうなんとかなんとか言って
ものすごいどんどんどんどんものすごい暗くなるんですよ
関わり持ちたい持ちたいと思うたびに
どんどん暗くなって暗くなって
もうもうものすごい嫌な存在になります
ですから 阿羅漢の人っていうのは
それほど深く関わりを持ってるんではなくて
その場その場でやることはちゃんとやってます
それで終わりということでね
で いちいち持ってはいかないんですね
心の中に うん で 関わり期待した人にとっては
もうあらゆる問題が出てきて
暗くなるだけじゃなくて
関わり持てなくなるで
ものすごく怒りも出てきて
破壊的にもなったりしてね
もうものすごい残酷な状態になっちゃうんですね
だから心はすごく自由に完璧にものすごくということは関わりは持てないという状態なんですけど
だから関わり持たないということは
まあ悟っているということなんですね
人間に関わる関する関わりと
それと違う 天に関わる
まあ関する関わりという
いわゆる人間と天で言ったらサッバンヨーガ
全ての関わりをもうなくなっていますと
サッバヨーガウィサンユッタン
一切の関わりから離れていて
その人がタマハンブルーミブラフマナン
バラモンであると私は言いますと
それより この なんでこういう偈が出ましたかというと
別にストーリーはそんなに関係ないことなんですけど
あるこの踊り子の人がいてね
まあ大道芸人ですね まあかなり踊って
まあ人から何か収入を得て生活していて
まあある日この人がもう説法を聞いて
まあ出家するんですね
出家してすぐ間もないうちに悟ってしまうんですね
だからこの大道芸人がまだまだその西行に方にいるんです
それで托鉢にお釈迦様と一緒に托鉢に出ていくということで
すごい前の芸人の仲間たちがまあいろんな芸を見せたり踊ったりしているんですよ
だからプロという場合は
やっぱりすぐ心が惹かれるっていうのはプロの世界なんですよ
だからずっと踊って 音楽を演奏したり
踊ったり あらゆる工夫を見せたりした人にとっては
もうまあ仲間がね また同じことをやっていると
まあすぐ利点も取ったくなるなり取りたくなるのは全くごく普通なことなんです
それはもうおかしいことでもなんでもないんです
絵を描くプロがいてね
それ出家して絵を描くことをやめたとしたっても
誰か一生懸命絵を描いてみると
なんとなくもう見ていたくはなるんですよ
だからプロっていうのはそういうことだからね
慣れて慣れてる生活だからね
ですから 他の坊さんたちが
やっぱりこの人は踊りのプロということでね
これプロの前で仲間たちがあらゆる芸を見せたり踊ったりすると
これは必ず心が惹かれるんだよと
だから 踊りを見て楽しむ人よりは
この引き方が違うんですよ
プロの場合は ですから
それはもうすごく違うレベルで心が惹かれてしまう
だから 他の坊さんたちは
君の心も恐らく踊っているでしょうと
だから 素人より分かっているでしょうね
今何の音楽やっていますかとかね
今はどういう様相でやればいいかとかね
その場合はどんな楽器つなげてくるかとか
どういう それは全部わかっているんだからね
ですから その聴いていると同時に
心は結局はこの芸と一緒に動く
動いているはずなんですよ
なかなか大変で それを避けられないんですよ
プロの場合は 例えばバイオリンを弾ける人がいて
もう一人の人がバイオリンを弾いていると
それを普通聴いている人よりは
弾ける人の場合は もう心の中であのバイオリンの弦と弓と一緒にもう動いているんですよ
指も心の中できちんと動いているんですよ
それはなかなか大変なことなんですよ
だから あの 大体この感情でやっているものだから
例えばバイオリンでやっても
すごい高いハイピッチの音を出しちゃうと
演奏する人はすごく筋肉を硬くするんですよ
別にしなくてもいいんです
ただ指で押せちゃえばそれだけのことですけど
指で押せ 弦を押しても
そんなことなく弾いちゃえばいいんですけど
やっぱりそれではもううまく上手に指が動かないんですよ
感情に乗ってないと ですから
もう高い音でもすごい低い音でも
指とあれで別物ですけど
高い音になってくると
もう筋肉も全部硬くなっているし
それでよく低い 低い音だったら自分もすごく緩やかになってね
筋肉もなんだかんだという風に
だからそれプロのやり方で
それ他のプロが見ていると
自分の体も心も一緒に動いてしまうんですよ
だからこのストーリー
そのポイントだけすごく大事なポイントなんですね
人間の心というのは これごく普通な
私が知っている限りは
どんな人間にもある話なんですよ
うーん どうでしょうかね
いろいろプロの方々いるかもしれませんだけどね
そこでお坊さんたちが君の心も切り立ったん
君の心もおそらくおそらく踊っているんだよと周りのお坊さんたちが心配して言ったんですよ
やっぱり それはもうしょうがないしね
もう出家してもう何日も経ってないし
そこら辺ってやっぱり君の心も今はね
おそらく踊っているでしょうと
[背景音楽]これ心配して言ってるんですよ
そこでそのお坊さんはアッティノーケーエッテ・シネーホーと
やっぱり心はなんとなく
今はなんとなくだではなくて一緒に踊っているでしょうね
踊りたいっていう気持ちがやっぱりあるでしょうとか聞いたら
いえ 別に私の心は一緒に踊ってないんだよと
もう捨てちゃったんだから
そんなものはということを
それだけ言うんですね
そんなのもう捨てましたからね
全然心は一緒に踊ってないんだと
それでお坊さんたちにとっては
これはちょっと信じ難いんですよ
これちょっとおかしいと
もうすぐ今までずっとボロで大道芸人やっていた人が
もう全然興味ないと 一日二日で言えるはずがないんですね
それはちょっとおかしいと
そう言うんだったらね
やっぱりもうこれ五 六年経っても十年経ってもプロはプロだから
すぐもう引っ張ってしまっちゃうのは普通でしょうに
ですから これちょっとね
そんないい加減なこと言ったって認めませんと
心は踊るはずですよと
そこでお釈迦様が お釈迦様にそういうこととか
お釈迦様 あの人の心はやっぱりもうそういうものと一緒に共鳴して踊りませんと
だからお釈迦様は心の状況を知っているんだから
あの人の心はあれやこれやということって共鳴しませんと
もう安定しているんだと
ということで その考えでなんでかというと
やっぱりこの関わりという言葉からね
音楽っていうのは数々の関わりでしょうしね
音楽なんで演奏するかというと
やっぱり人々の心にも関わりを作りたいしね
そうやってこの そこから人間の世界の関わりっていうのをいっぱいやりまして
お金に関わりがあるわ
音楽 芸術に関わりがあるわとかね
で 財産やらね 自分の体
名誉とかね そういうものにも関わりがあると
関わりがなしには生きていられないんですね
人間にとっては 関わりっていうのは大変な苦しいことで
楽でもないし自由でもないし
でも関わりがないと生きていられないということになる
関わりがないと苦しいと
苦しくなるんだと というのは嘘で
関わりが欲しくて欲しくてでもない場合はえらい暗くなるんですよ
だから仏教はすごい暗いよというのは
そういう人々なんですね
あれこれといろんなところで関わりを持ちたいんですよ
持ちたいのは気持ちは良いんだけど
そんな能力も何もない
一人の二人の人間とも関わり持てるぐらいの能力はないんですよ
しょっちゅう話してみたら
その人に嫌がられるんで
あんたはちょっとごめんともう私は忙しいやと
だから人間と人間と仲良くしようというと
それはかなりのテクニックなんでしょうに
ただバカみたいに顔を見ていても仲良くしてくれないし
いい加減なことを言ったってもね
仲良くしてくれないし
それ何やっても嫌われるだけなんですよ
それはもう自分がすごいテクニックを持ってね
すごく明るく とにかく明るさと関わりを持たないことで人間が仲良くできますよ
でもそれはわからないんだからね
あの人ともこの人ともあの人とも
こういう世界中いろいろあらゆる人と人と関わりを持ちたいなという気持ちがあって
でもできない 一人一人
その場合はものすごく心が暗くなってしまっちゃうんですね
それで関わりは良くないというブッダの話で出て
やっぱり仏教は暗いと
てめえが暗えじゃな[笑い]
それは関係ないことなんですけどね
だから関わりから心が離れれば離れるほど
すごく明るくなるんですよ
すごく自由自在になるし
誰とも何のことなく おはよう
こんにちはと見えるし
出かけるとさよならということでさっさと出て行くこともできるし
何かやってくれ頼んだら
いや やってあげるぞということでやってあげることもできるし
で これでくっりを振りながら肩振りながらあっち見てこっち見て
これもう十年間かかるんですよ
頼んで何か仕事やってもらうまでは
それはもう明るい人の性格じゃないので
だから仏教的に関わりなくなった人は
そう 今これやるの？はい
やります やっちゃうと
それで終わった まあ終わりましたから
もう帰りますよということで
ものすごい明るく 鳥のようなね
心の状態で生活できるんです
だから鳥のような生活っていうのは関わりがすごい少ないっていうことで
だから誰とも関わりを持たないということは
決して暗いということじゃないんですし
関わり持ちたい人こそえらい暗いですね
本当はあらゆる関わりが持ってる人はね
それも能力あるんですよ
十人と付き合ってるんだよと
あるいは五人家族で頑張ってるんだぞとかね
いう人はそれぐらい能力持ってますよ
五人の精神的な面であれこれ見ていられると
でも実際自分の心に聞くと
なんとか放っとしてくれませんかと
自分のことという気持ちがいつもあるんですよ
十人の面倒を私が見てるんだから
いつでも出てきて 私は何でも解決してあげるぞ
相手にしてあげるぞとか
遊びたい時は遊び相手にしてあげるぞとかね
ご飯食べたいんだったらすぐ料理作ってあげるぞとか
こんなやりきれないんですよ
住人と関わりを持ってる人にしても
それはあくまでも自分にはその分は体力
精神力があるんだからやってるんであって
それでも心に聞けばちょっと放っておいてくれませんかと
そういう気持ちはいつでもあるんですよ
だから関わり自体がそんなに楽しいものでもないんです
疲れるんですよ やりきれなくなっちゃうんですよ
これは能力ある人の場合
能力ない人は関わりはどんなほど苦
どれほど苦しいかわからないんですよ
あ あの二人がすごく仲良く遊んでいて
ああ 羨ましいなとかね
そんなもんじゃないんですよ
その二人が仲良く遊んでるのはそれぐらい能力あるんだからでしょうし
でもそれでかなり疲れるんですけど
それでこちらが私もそれだけ仲良くしたいなと思うと
どんどんものすごく苦しくなると
それは関わり持ちたいと思うことだけでも
ものすごく苦苦が出てくるし
関わりそれなりに持ってる人にしたってもろくなことがないし
疲れてしまうだけであってね
何のこともないっていうことで
だからこの心は何にも関わらないという共鳴しない心を作るということをね
それがもう阿羅漢のというかね
悟りの心なんですね 今まで自分が見たい踊りがありまして
自分の何でしたっけ？すごいファンのタレントがいて
で 見たくてたまらなかったと
でもその人が自分はそこら辺に来て
踊りやらいろんなことをやっているというような
前ではね でも何のこともないと
心は で 心は共鳴しない
ああ やっぱりもう昔は見たかったなとかね
今日でも見られてよかったとかね
そういう気持ちはないところは
もう心は共鳴しないんですね
だから心にその状態があるかないかとね
いわゆる智慧の世界でね
で いい加減なことじゃないんです
だから智慧がある人は
自分が自分の心が共鳴しないということを知ってます
それぐらいのことで そんなもんでとかね
だから心はあらゆるものに
いろんなものに共鳴しない状態が
このこちらでヨーガという言葉で使ってます
で 四十八は四十八じゃなくて百十八
ヒットワラティンチェアラティンチェ・シーティ・ブータン・ニルーパディン・サブダ・ローカ・ビブー・ヴィーラング・タマハン・ブーミ・ブラフマナン
ヒットワ・ラティンチェ・アラティンチェ・シーティ・ブータン・ニルーパディン・サブダ・ローカ・ビブー・ヴィーラング・タマハン・ブーミ・ブラフマナン
まあラティとアラティって両方ヒットは捨てて
ラティっていうのはもう執着すること
楽しみですね 欲ですね
ああ 楽しいとかね アラティっていうのはそちらの反対ですね
まあこちらは寂しさと書いてますけど
まあ嫌になることたらね
で スィーティ・ブータン・ニルーパディン
まあとにかく好き嫌いが心にないというぐらいの意味で
パティヤラティ ティクトワラ・テンチャラ・テンチャ
好き嫌いは心にはない
捨てています で 心はスィーティ・ブータン
スィーティっていうのはこの涼しくなったというね
冷静ですね 冷静になってになりまして
ニルーパディン ウパディっていうのは汚れですよ
汚れはない ニルーパディン
そこでサッバ・ローカン
サッバっていうのはすべてのローカンっていうのは世界をアビブン
征服していると 打ち勝っているということで
すべての世界を征服しているヴィーラン
ヴィーランというのは何でしたっけ？戦争に勝った人には何とか言うんですね
まあヒーローですね ヴィーランというのはヒーローということですね
ヒーローは日本語で何とか言いますね
英雄 うん ヴィーランというのは英雄ですね
そこで まあそれぐらいのこと
それがバラモンであると
覚った人であると だから覚った人っていうのは好き嫌いはない
心は冷静 で 汚れはない
そこまではなんとかわかりますね
それで すべての生命に
生命を すべての世界を
サッバっていうのは一切の世界を征服しているっていうのは何なのかと
どういう意味ですかね
それは  すべての世界 すべての世界といえば
まあ大体は生命という意味で
仏教は世界ということをとってます
あの 決して物理学的な
この この空間的な世界のことを言ってるわけじゃないんですね
空間的な世界っていうのはそんなに大したことないしね
もう それを征服はできませんし
誰にも まあ一応 まあ一平方メートルぐらいでも
この世界の空間を征服できますかね
いくらこれが私のものじゃ
自分のものじゃないんだからね
だからまあ 物理的なことっていうのは
まあ征服も自分のものにすることはまるっきりできません
一つも ですから もう管理できるのは生命の世界です
だから生命が世界と仏教で言うんですよ
それは管理できますよ
みんな心を持ってますから
だから一平方のメートルの土地をね
これ私のものと言ったっても
そのまんまでその場所で動く
動きはしませんだから
その土地は どうすることもできないんですよ
でも人だったらこっち来いとあっち行けとかね
まあ言うことできるでしょうね
そうするとこっち来いと言ったら
その人はこちらに来るし
あっち行って 行きなさいと言ったらそちらへ行ってしまうしね
だって生命の場合は管理っていうのは成り立つんですよ
だからこの政治家やらね
昔の人々はね  まあ国と国戦って
あの国は私のものにしましたよと言ったっても
国は自分のものになりません
その人々を殺したんだっていうことですよ
だから残された人々は怖くて
その人言うことは聞くと
それだけのことで あの国も私はもう征服しましたと
この国も私は征服しましたっていうことをまあ言うんですよ
だからそうやって国と国と戦う場合でも
みんなわかってない 国も取れませんということを
そちらで人間と人間の
あの 殺し合いだけであって
そこでまあ殺される側がもう
もう嫌だから もう一応ね
まあ言うことを聞くと
でも気持ち込めて 思って言うこと聞くわけじゃないんですよ
ものすごい気持ちは逆反対なんですよ
できれば殺してやると
でも向こうは強いんだから
もう黙って言うことを聞くというぐらいなんです
だから あの戦争で勝ったっていう
勝って何か誰かを征服したんだということは
それこそものすごい危険なことで
ちょっと間違うともう敵に回すんだから殺しちゃうんだから
だから 例えば人をそうやって征服したならば
ずっとその人のことを危険人物で願っておかないと楽じゃないんですよ
人を征服することっていうのは
征服したならば 私は力でその人を抑えたってことでしょうと
その人が怖くて もうはいわかりました
言うことやりますということになります
でもこちら力が力で抑えてるんだからなんですよ
ですから気持ちは逆なんですね
気持ち力で抑える場合
向こうも力で抑圧するでしょうに
私は相手を殺していると相手は私を殺しているし
ですから それで私の方が力が強いとわかったら
向こうはいわかりましたと
報復やと もう言うことやりますと言っても
それがものすごい危険な状態なんですね
ちょっとでも緩んじゃうと
もう全部爆発しちゃうということになるんですね
ですから 必ず向こうも抑えた国っていうのは
騒乱やらいろんなものが起きちゃいますよ
それを避けられません
ですから ただ戦争で人と勝って戦って勝っても
もうただのアホバカやと
勝ってないんだと 負けてるんだと
ただ敵作ってるだけやっていうことは仏教の思考なんですね
誰も認めてないんですけど
勝てるんだよと そう思ってますけど
ブッダはいえ 勝てませんと
勝ったと言っても これはもう敵をたくさん作ったことであって
どうやって勝って勝ったと言うんでしょうかと
だからそれも使ってね
他のところでは戦争で勝つ人は勝ったではないんだと
心を勝った人が本当の英雄だと
だから私が言うことをやってほしいでしょ
相手の人が やってくれないんだから殺してやると言うでしょ
そうすると自分が力強くて抑えたと
勝ちましたと 私が言うこと全部やってくれると
勘違いなんですね でもその人はもう心は私の言うことをやってあげたくなったらどうしますかね
殴る必要もないし 脅す必要もないんです
いわゆる私のことをすごく好きで気に入って
信頼して 向こうは勝手にあなたが言うことだったら何でもしてやってあげますと
実はそれで 10人  100人
1万人 もう 1,000万人ぐらい人々がそういうことを言っちゃうと
この人はどんな人間になるんですかね
いきなり王様になってしまっちゃうでしょうに
だから勝つんだったら心を勝たせなくちゃいけないんですよ
相手に勝つならば 相手の心に勝てと
でなきゃ意味がないんだと
これ昔の仏教の論理なんですね
そういうことだから このこのこの論理もたまたまあの他のところでは堂々と使ってて
北教の偈はありましたけど
こちらはそれほど関係ないんだけど
もしかするとこの偈のこのバランスをちゃんと左と右をね
ちゃんと取らないとあかんだから
こちらでこのサッベローカー・ヴィブン・ヴィーランという言葉を入れてるんですね
すべての世界を乗り越えて征服しているんだと
すべての人間を征服しているんだと
そこでこの征服した人と征服されている人の生き方は何なのかと
[背景音楽]どういう生き方ですかね
戦略者と戦略される人
だから支配する側は命令する
支配される側は命令を実行する
それが世の中の生き方なんです
今日からちょっと勉強してみてください
世の中で生きたことがないんだったら
あの 一人が命令する 一人が実行するというシステムで世の中できているんです
犬を飼ったら 犬を飼っている飼い主が支配者であって
飼われて犬が支配されているんですよ
だから飼い主が命令する犬は実行する
それは逆にはなりませんよ
私にとってはすごい単純な論理なんですけど
一応勉強してみてください
世の中は一応そういう風になっているんです
どこを見ても一人が命令して
一人が実行すると そこで支配すると支配されるという 2つ成り立ってるんですよ
それで支配する側は命令するだけで
支配される側にとっては言われる通りに動かなくちゃいけないんです
だから支配されている人っていうことは
まあ世間の命令通りに動くんであって
自分の自由っていうのはないんです
支配される側がいくら命令しても
支配する側は聞きません
聞きたければ聞く 聞きたくないんだったら聞かないと
犬は外へ出たくてくて鳴いたり吠えたりしていると
飼ってる人が自分でも気分が向いてるんだったら
じゃあ散歩に行こうと
もう出て行きたくない
もうご飯食べて寝るんだ
黙っていろと うるさいといて自分が寝る
散歩に連れて行かない
いくら鳴いても だから支配する側が聞かないんですよ
命令を 支配される側はもう聞くしか方法ないんです
だから私たちもあの人
あらゆるいろんなことを言われることは実行しているんですよ
言われた通りに それはすごく支配されているんだからなんです
自分の意思でやりたいんだからやってるんだよということはなかなかないんですよ
その方がすごい 例えば
飼い主が犬を連れて散歩に行くと
自分に暇がある時は散歩に連れて行くんだから
別に犬に散歩させてる気持ちじゃないでしょうに
犬に飼われているんだと
ですからこの人の仕事をしても
自分が好きでやっているんだよと
誰かの命令ではないんだと
やってる仕事はみんなの役に立つようにしてあげますけど
別にもうあなたに必要だからやってるのに
あなたに命令されたんだからやってるよって
そういうことはね あなたのこと怖いんだからやってるんだよということでも何でもなく
その場合は自由というものは成り立ってしまうんですね
普段はそれはないんですね
上の命令に従ってやりましたと
ですからこの犬生ですよ
それはもう全ての人間持ってます
どうか命令してくださいと
その通りにやると といってもできません
能力ないんだから 言われた通りにやれませんよ
それで失敗する それですごいまた不幸になる
罰やらもういろいろ もう罰金やら
もうあらゆるものを重ねてくるんですよ
なぜならばもう言われる通りにしますよと言っているのに
それさえもできないんですよ
犬の場合も同じことでしょう
まあお座りとかね じゃあ待てと言っても
待てできない時もあります
犬には だからみんな犬を調教するんだと言ってね
待てと言ったら犬はもうずっと待っていなくちゃいけないんですね
それでおいしいものが口になるんだけど
もう行って食べて食べてはいけませんから
ずっと待っているんです
それではいと言ったら
また立ち上がってその餌を食べるという風に訓練しているでしょうね
でもいくらなんでも待てと言っても待てない犬もいますよ
待てと言ってもわかってはいるんだけど
すぐ行って食べちゃうと
だからそれは失敗です
人間の場合もこの待てはできない人間というのは結構います
それで 仕事中でも 家庭の中でも
会社でも 電車の中でも
どこでも失敗 失敗 失敗
失敗の人生で それは待てもできない犬人生なんですよ
ですから この命令に従って生きるっていうことは
どんな人間のも生き方なんですよ
支配者はいません 支配者がいたっても
その人を誰かまた支配しているんだから
一つのネットワークなんですよ
お互いに支配しているんです
お互いに支配されているんです
で 会社の先はもう社員に対しては偉そうに怒鳴って
もう神様気分で怒鳴ったりするんですけど
まあ他の自分の品物を売って買ったりする
他の会社に行って まあ犬みたいに土下座して頭下げたり下げたりしているんだからね
どうかどうかよろしくお願い致します
どうかよろしくお願い致します
こちらに来たら 自分の社員たちには偉そうに怒鳴ったりするんでしょうね
だからどっちが上だ そちらですよ
向こうに行ったら犬で
こちらに行ったら自分の社員たちが犬で
自分が飼い主で そうやってもうもうネットワークになってますね
人間の世界っていうのは
だからもう全ての人間が誰かの誰かって一人ではなくてね
多数の人々の奴隷なんですよ
無数の多数の人々の奴隷なんです
どんな人から調べても
その人は多数の人々の奴隷で
ですから 言われる通りにするしか何もない
もししなかったら 自分の人生はすごい危うく状態になります
何年夫婦やっていたっても
私は命令聞きませんと命令に背く場合はね
まあ 2 3週間でもう不結婚生活なし
お前は勝手にしなさいということになるんですよ
だからもう安定はないんですよ
命令に従わない限りは
ですからみんなこのお腹の食い物の安定のために
もう一生懸命命令に従って生きているんですね
だから人類が人の命令を聞いているんだから
征服しているわけじゃないんですよ
誰も 結局は征服することはできないんですね
結局は 征服はしたいんだけどできない
社長が怒鳴ったりしたっても
いきなり社員たちがね
腹が立って あんた何様やとやらんと思ったらそれだけで終わっちゃいますから
何もできないんだから
そんな会社では仕事をしませんと
で それじゃああんた方をクビにしますよ
そう簡単におクビにすることもできません
それでまたそれなりのお金を払わなくちゃいかんしね
だからそれ損するでしょうに
それで他の人々が入れたって
また同じことをじゃあ私たちもやりませんと
これ成り立たんでしょうに
だから たとえ社長がもうそうやってもうみんな支配してやるぞと思ったって
そううまくは成り立たないし
うーん だからといって
我々は奴隷で生きていなくてはいけていられないしね
だから上手の奴隷はかなりまあうまく世の中で生きているということになるんで
だから世界人生うまくいってる人に限って
このすごい奴隷性がすごい強いんですよ
うまくいかない人の場合は奴隷性は少ない
でもその分はまあ南口に住むことになる
あります 新宿駅の [笑い]人の話聞かなかったら
人の話を聞いて まあ飼われてる犬で生活すると
まあ南口に出れなくても
それなりの自分の家で住んで
自分好きなご飯食べて生活することができるんですね
だからこの世俗的な人生はね
成功しているかないかということは
仏教の目から見ると見ると
そういう解釈になるんですよ
支配すると支配されるの
この関係で でも世の中で誰一人も絶対的な支配者がいないと
いると言ったら これ頭が悪いだけなんです
絶対的な支配者はいません
その戦災の中で いるというのは
それは頭がおかしい 例えば日本の社会を見ると
私たちには力がないんだけど
まあそこの地方の議員には力があるとかね
公務員というのなんとか力があるんじゃないか
自分よりは もうもったいぶらって支配してますかね
そうはできませんよ それでもっと上がいるんだから
もっと上がいるんだから
それでもっと上調べて調べていると
まあ小泉さんという人に出会うんですね
まあその一番上やと では
あなた一人勝手で何でもできます
法律はそうなんですよ
全部自分勝手できますけどね
誰を大臣にしようか 誰をクビにしようか
全部できるんだと そこぐらい力持ってますけど
あんた自分勝手できます？できませんね
何一つも自分勝手にはできませんですよ
どれだけじゃあ小泉さんが偉いかというと
それでもないし 小泉さんが天皇陛下に認定されますからね
では天皇陛下すごいかというと
何一つも力がないんですね
[笑い]うかつにしゃべったら大変なことになるんだからね
喋る権利もない 自由もないと
ということになる だから結局は天皇陛下といっても
ものすごい要請の人々にもう支配されちゃって
命令されちゃって生活しているでしょうに
で 逆に他の人々も もうまた
なんかバカバカしい世界ですよ
まあ皇室だったらね そちら仕事する人々はもう結局天皇陛下はその人々に命令してるでしょ
まあこれはこういうしますよ
これをこうしますよと
これは原稿ですよとかね
この時間でこちらに出かけますよとかなんとかとかね
そこでその方々は この仕事をする人々の命令に従って
これでよろしい これでよろしいとかね
聞きながら仕事をしなくちゃいけない
なかなかそういう皇室の方々もいる
何にも単なる雇われているだけのことで
で 逆にこちらから見れば
もう全部天皇陛下やら何やら何やら
その人のためにやってるんだから
もう一生懸命緊張しながらまたやられる
だからどちらがどちらかわからないんですよ
誰が誰をもう奴隷にしているかっていう
だから私はあなたを奴隷にする
その代わりにあなたは私を奴隷にしなさいという約束なんですよ
だからそれが世俗的な生き方なんですよ
もし命令聞かないんだったら
もう奴隷じゃないでしょ
命令聞く必要ないと だからこの野良犬はお座りって言ったらお座りしてくれないでしょ
野良犬にお座りって言ってみてください
私が言ったらやりますけどね
それは別の話で 皆さんは言ってみてください
私は番犬でもすぐもう
じゃあこれやってくださいって言ったらやってくれますよ
こちらにいる間はちゃんと見張っておけと
まあそれは別なやり方がありますからね
普通は野良犬にお座りって言ったって
野良犬から見ると なんであんた何様のつもりこのバカと
本当に悔しいでしょうね
でも自分飼ってる犬にとっては
それはできませんね お座りって言ったらお座りして
もうだからもうちょっともう可愛い顔を見せて
もうもうなんて言いますか
よくもうああ可愛い可愛いと言ってもらえて
それでもう納得いくでしょうに
ですから この命令聞けないということは自由ということなんです
命令聞く必要はないんだと
で それ一つ 今言ったのは
人間関係の成り立つ奴隷関係
奴隷と支配者の関係 だから必ずしも支配者が奴隷にならなくちゃいけないし
奴隷も必ずしも支配者にならなくちゃいけないという条件なんですよ
その条件で こちらは奴隷だったら
こちらは支配者 こちら奴隷
奴隷になってくると支配者になってくると
こちらまた奴隷と まあそれどちらでも変わるんですよ
ぐるぐるぐるぐる で たまたまこちらもどれこちらもどれになってくるとうまくいかなくなっちゃうんですよ
夫婦の場合はこちらも支配者でこちらも支配者で
もううまくいかないんですよ
そうすると だからもう男も支配者で女も支配者になっちゃうと
すぐぶつけてもうまくいかないし
女も支配されて側で男も支配されてたら全然うまくいかないんですね
どちらでもダメなの だからぐるぐるぐるぐる変わるとうまくいくんですよ
女が命令すると男は聞く
と 男が命令すると女は聞くという
そうやってこの役柄をね
ちゃんとぐるぐる変わると
正しく変わると何一つ問題は起こりません
だからこれぐるぐる変わるもんだから
時々同じ面はあったりしますよ
何一つ問題は起こりません
だからこれぐるぐる変わるもんだから
時々同じ面はあったりしますよ
もう変わってからそこで支配者の面と
こちらの面と こちらも支配者
本当は支配されてる面でこそだったけど
もう支配者の面です こちら
いや あなたは面が違うよと
いえ あなたが変えなさいと
ということになっちゃうんです
それでケンカになるとかね
だから人間関係トラブルってのはそうやってこの支配するされるのを
このちょっとちったからくりが起きる
それはあくまでも自然なことなんですよ
で コイン 2つ まあこうやって上にあげる
投げすと一つヘッド 一つテールであればなければいかんと
ヘッドでなんて言いますね
表と裏 だからコイン 2つ投げるんだから
必ずその結果は表と裏でなければいけませんということなんですけど
時々表だけで 時々裏だけでも出ますからね
それは避けられません
それで人間関係の場合も
支配者支配されるという関係なんですけど
まあ時々まあ同じもの出てしちゃう場合もありますね
その時は必ずぶつかっちゃう
支配者の面だけ出るとぶつかっちゃうし
支配される側の面だけ出てきちゃうとぶつかるということはないんだけど
もうすごい もう何もやらない
もう堕落しちゃうというかね
ろくな状態になっちゃうんですね
うん まあそこまでは人間関係でもう一つ奴隷っていうのはあるんですよ
例えばここら辺でもそろそろ花が咲くと思いますけど
すぐ自分も惹かれてしまうんですよ
花に管理される 綺麗に花が咲いたら美しい香りが出てくるともう我慢できなくなり
それに奴隷化されるんですよ
だから私が思うほど まあドラマ
日本  NHK の朝の朝ドラマありますね
あれ時々見たことありますけど
私はその中でなんか海女さんのお寺の場面が出てくるんですが
そちら辺のドラマはすごく内容はいいし
あのダイアログでもかなり面白いというか
意味深いことやらね 役に立つことやらよく言ってますよ
ですからその分は 面白くて見ていたんですけどね
で メインドラマはまああんまりもうバカバカらしい
もういいところでもうそこ
まあそれはそれでまあいいんですけど
一応この食べ物ですね
やってるのは もうどれほど神経使ってどれほど難しいかと
この大根煮ることはね
そこでゴマをね 蜜につけて
それからすり鉢でまあこうやってするでしょ
それごま豆腐 これがなかなか難しいと
かなりアホやと思いますけどね
まあそこはそっちゃえば
物理学的にはどちらでも同じなんですけどね
もういくらこうやっても戦場に入ってすると
だからまあそこまで まあとにかく心が乱れると
食べ物をどんなものでも乱れることは確かですけどね
心が乱れるとね ろくな結果は出てこないんですけど
だからといって もう食い物にとそこまでというのはね
ちょっとやりすぎというのはすごいもうやりすぎなんですね
で それはそれで文化だからね
しょうがないんですけど
私は宗教の目で見るんですね
どれほどこの人々は食べるものに奴隷かという
もうこれはもう末期状態で
もう地獄からはいくら踏ん張っても取り出すことはできないんだと
そこまで執着しちゃうと
もう諦めた方がいいんです
将来は だからそこら辺はだから文化だからそのままいいんですよ
文化っていうのは結構苦しいというかね
そう簡単ではないしね
まあごま豆腐作るわよ
こういう風に作って 切る場合はこういう風に角が出て
こういう風に切るんだぞと
でなきゃ美味しくないわけじゃなくて
でなきゃかっこ悪いやと
これ切り目がね こうやって
それかっこ悪いよと それ日本の文化やと
縦切るところでもピッとして切っておくっていうことは
これは私たちの文化だよという場合は
もうすごくいいんだ 私もそれすると習いたくなるんですよ
もう威張ってやってるんだから
じゃあやってやるぞと
自分もということになるんですよ
そうじゃないんですよ
これは深い意味があるんだと
これは無念で無心で まあ肉体のこと言いたくなるね
その場合は そこまで執着しちゃうとよくないんですね
だから文化としてのは悪いわけじゃないんですよ
大根を切ることは簡単じゃないやと
こういう風に こういう風に大根の皮をむいて
こういう風に切るんだよ
そこまではいいんだけど
その場合は外人にでもね
あんたにできるかやってみなさいと言ったら
いやできないということになるでしょうね
そこまで文化で威張れますよ
すごく でもこうやって角を切ってないと美味しくないんだというところはね
すごくもう変ですよ だからそれはまあ世界は仏教は知りませんだからね
感情愛情だけしか知りませんから
やっぱりこの食べ物にどれほど奴隷になっているかというね
ものすごい奴隷 だから奴隷になりすぎて
結局味がわからないんですよ
そこら辺 すごく疑いがあるんですね
本当に日本の人々 味がわかってるんでしょうかという
すごく いや 別にあの 大げさで嫌で嫌味で言ってるわけじゃなくて
時々ちょっと何かそう疑いが出てくるんですよ
本当にわかってるかな
ただ ただ決まり文句で言ってるんではないかと
という 例えばこのイチゴをね
いろんな種類が改良するでしょ
今度はこういうイチゴ
なんとか改良 何々っていう名前でね
一緒にこれこれも改良しましたよって出てくる
宣伝したりするんです
それで 1番目の主流のイチゴだから
ああ やっぱりすごく美味しくて歯触りが云々とかので
それじゃあこれ これまた同じことなんですね
甘くてね もう もうなんとかなんとかがあって
なんか何か言うんですよ
全部同じなんですよ 言葉もなんだかんだも
わかってるんですか？だから本当の提出するんだったら
そんなかっこよくて こうやってやるんじゃなくて
イチゴ２つ取って これ食べてみて
これ食べてみて これはこれこれで
これはこれこれという
あまり綺麗なもんじゃないんですよ
テスターの場合は だからイチゴはこうやってとって
まあ全然わからないと思いますよ
だからこの食べるもので
よく皆様方ね いろんなごちそうのことを知ってますから
あの どれほど我々はやられているかと
奴隷化されているかというね
そこら辺は理解してほしい
美味しいものを食べろなんていう意味じゃないんですよ
料亭なんかに行くなよということじゃないんですよ
まあ借金してでも料亭に行ってご飯食べてくださいってことはないんです
サラ金から追いかけ逃げて下さい
その時はまあ それぐらいまあ食べ物には一応執着は捨てて
理解してほしいのは この食べ物は我々は奴隷にしているということなんです
そこで服も我々は奴隷にしている
で 音も我々は奴隷にしている
いくら自分がステレオを買ってないとかね
もう MD 持ってないとかね
もう音楽あまり聞きたくないと言ったっても
もしどこかで演奏でもやっているんだったらどうしますかね
もう今の時間になってくると
あの高島屋のタイムスクエアというところがありましてね
そこら辺ちょっと行ってみたら
もうまあ歳 の男の子女の子たちがね
いろいろこと遊んでいるんですよ
だから まあ私みたいなね
じじい見たってまあもう可愛いと思っちゃいますよ
子供たちがね こいつら家から出てきて
親が心配しているのに
偉そうに遊んでるや なんかすごく子供っていう気持ちが出てくるんですよ
親父ったら何もやらないのに
何か音楽に合わせてどうやって合わせて踊るかと一生懸命やってるんだからね
まあせいぜい頑張れという気持ちが生まれてくるし
だからそれ分でも やっぱり気持ち
自分にとっても気持ちは確かに穏やかでしょうしね
だからこの まあこちらがもうじじいだからね
そういう気持ちになるんですけど
もし他のね 音楽好きな人とかね
踊りが好きな人とかね
そこら辺行ったらすぐもう惹かれると
惹かれると思いますよ
で たまたまね 秋葉原に行くんだか秋葉原にいたって
まあ時 時半 時になってくると
なんかこの音楽隊が来るんですよ
いつでも同じグループで
昔からもう顔も飽きちゃったんです
何音楽でしたね あれ あの
こうやって あの そうそう
南米のね だから今日も同じ
でももう何十年も聞いてますけどね
まあ私はあの まあ能力は確かにね
音楽家だからね 能力は認めたいんですよ
能力はあるんだと でもその能力
その音楽で人をもう操るって
それはできませんと あんた方にはね
その声も その出す音も
私の耳にはもうあまり綺麗に映りませんと
でも君たちの能力は認めると
この若者のグループがね
まあそれなりの能力があって
何か CD なんか売って
それで生活していたいんですからね
だから聞きたくないんだから CD は買わないんだけど
なんとなくその連中に対してはね
愛情があるんですよ だから枚ぐらいで買ってあげようかな
買ってどうするんですか
私は それは  [笑い]ということでは買わないんですけどね
まあそれでもそういう南米の音楽好きな人だったら
まあ足を引っ張ってまあ止まるでしょうにね
だから我々の我々はやっぱり音すごく危ないんですよ
出たらすぐ奴隷にする可能性ありますね
こちらを で 花も危ないんですよ
ただのもう何のこともない
もう空たらの鎖かけてる花なのに
人を奴隷にするという
大変なことなんですよ
そこでデパートなんか行っても
お茶なんかを売ってるところあるでしょうに
あれでなんかお茶の煙出してるでしょ
ね なんとかの機械とかわかりませんだけど
日本茶っていうのはそんなにこの紅茶みたいに焼いちゃうと
もう品質品質がすごく悪くなっちゃうし
すごくこのややこしいんだからね
日本茶っていうのはね
それでもあの香りが上手に焼いて出すんですね
だからそこら辺は全部このすごい気持ちのいい日本茶の香り
だからそれも人はいかに奴隷化にしようかというね
奴隷にしようかというね
客引き術ですよ だからそういう風に我々はこの人間関係の奴隷システムは勉強した方がいいんですよ
無事生きて生きれば生きたければ
で それだけではうまくいかないんですけど
やっぱり我々は完全に奴隷なんですね
現に出身の そこでまあ
その世界からね 誰にもこちらに阿羅漢になった人には命令することはできない
例えばいっぱい桜の花が咲いて
私って綺麗でしょうと言ったって
勝手にしなさいと 私は忙しいということでなっちゃうんですよ
だから花の命令は効かないんですよ
だから他の何でもね 私って綺麗でしょうという風に
いろんなことが目に触れても
別にもう何のことない
それで音楽の場合でも
この音楽はどう この音楽をどうというあらゆるものを触れても
自分が奴隷になれない
人間関係の場合も同じことで
それでも奴隷になれない
あなたは私言うことを聞かなきゃご飯あげませんよと言ったら
あ そう じゃあご飯いりません
帰りますと それで行くんですよ
例えば比丘が来て托鉢に来たんだと
もうこちらすごい色々美味しいご飯がありまして
まあ実は今これからお布施はしますけど
ちょっとこれなんとかその前にやってくれませんかと
言ったら まあいいですと
ご飯は 隣の家に行きますと
命令できないんですよ
で それ場合ももう阿羅漢だから
やりたければやるんですよ
実はお家の息子が本当に病気で
なんかもう何かに取り憑かれてるかもしれませんですけど
どうかお坊さんせっかく来たんだからね
息子のこと見てもらいくれません？って
あ そう 子供病気ですかと
じゃあ何とかしますよ
自分の気持ちでやるんで
その場合は 言って まあなんとかして病気治してあげるかもしれませんと言ったら
素晴らしいですね お坊様がね
子供はすごい元気になりましたから
どうせ座ってことお布施しますよと言ったら
それは受け取りません
そうすると奴隷なんです
あなたのご飯は結構ですよと
自分で食べなさいと でも遅くなって
今日隣の他の家にも托鉢に行く時間ないでしょうと
まあそれは放っておけと
食べなくなってもこのご飯食べないんだと
という感じになる だから奴隷化することはできないんですね
だからと言って人の話は聞かないわけでもないし
人の仕事をやってあげないわけでもない
もう自分がやりたければやってあげる
説法したければ説法する
条件はない あなたに説法しますけど
あなたはこういうこういうことをしてくださいと
そうすると奴隷だからね
それは一切ない うん だからもう
だからこの その場合は
例えば悟った人が人に何か頼んでやってもらう時あるでしょ
これ奴隷システムないんだから
相手が気持ちよくやってくれるんですよ
ありがとうございます
やらせていただいてという
悟ったらそんな場合なんですね
だから頼むこともあれこれくだらんことを頼むわけでもないしね
あの人を殺してくれとかね
あの人を殴ってこいとかね
そういうことは絶対頼みませんし
頼んだっても正しい真理のことしか頼みはしませんしね
で 誰でもやりたがることしか頼みはしないですし
だからもう頼んだって
もう頼まれた側はもう喜んで
もうやらせてください
やらせてくださいとやるんだから
もう支配していますよ
阿羅漢は 命令しているんだから
逆に命令 阿羅漢に命令しようと思ったら
これは不可能で 不可能というか無効なんですね
なりたたない やりませんけどと
はっきり答えるんです
あんた何かする？それにと
でお釈迦様にそうやって命令出したの
一回 何回もありましたよ
この阿羅陀という夜叉なんですけども
もうお釈迦様はものすごい気が荒っぽい神霊ですけどね
勝手に家に入ったんです
で ドンと座って であまりにもうちに入っちゃったんだから
いくら夜叉であろうとも
あまりにも堂々としていると
ちょっとなんかちょっとこれはどうかなってちょっと心配する
そこで脅かしてね まあ脅して追い出そうとしたんだけど
行かない いろいろいたずら
嫌がらせする 気にしないね
座ったままでいる どうしようかと
だから気に入らんし あんた出ていってよと言ったの一言だ
言ったら あ そう はい わかりました
出て行きますと なんのその
出て行ったんです それでこの神霊が
私はずっと踏ん張って踏ん張って
あらゆる嫌がらせをしてね
もうヘタヘタなのに 簡単に出て行って言えばよかった
ちょっとどいてくださいと言ったら
どいてくれたのね  で もうそれをすぐに考えたのは
それでももしかするとね
私のことを腹が立って出て行ったかもしれませんと
まだ心配ですよ もうちょっと試そうと思ったら
どうぞ入ってくださいと
言ったら あ そう じゃあ入りますと言って
またお釈迦様入って座ったんですよ
言ったらこの また試しに出て行ってくださいと
お釈迦様 はい わかりましたと出て行って
また帰ってくる また帰ってくる
ああ なんだ こいつはもう言うこと何でもするんだと
だったら今までいくらでも
もうなんて言いますか
いじめできない感じでしたからね
使えるまでやらせるんだと
これはもう言う命令よくやる人やと言って
三回もあんた出ていってくださいと
出て行きませんだけどね
出て行きませんよと言われる通りに
あんた何かする？出て行かなかったら
だから二回目は まあお釈迦様はこの人はとにかくバカにして
もう支配してやるぞと
ということだから その分だけお釈迦様が言う通りにして
三回もやりませんと言ったら
もうじゃあ質問するんだと
答えなかったら足で捕まって
もう川の向こう側に捨てるんだよと
あのね 私は足を取ってね
川の向こう側に捨てられる人間
どんな夜叉にも鬼にもできませんだけどね
そんなことどうでもいいんだけど
質問があるんだったら聞きなさい
答えてあげますと すごいお釈迦様
そういう態度をとるんですよ
この世の中で私をそうと足で捕まって
向こう川の向こう側 まあいわゆるっていうね
まあ何話っていうんですか
そういう なんかね まあよくある
まあお互いね 威嚇するとき使う言葉ですけどね
あそこさんもね お釈迦様を脅かしてやるぞと
我々もスリランカ語ではよく言うんです
お前を海の向こう側に捨ててやるぞとかね
海の向こう側じゃなくて
家の外には出せませんですけど
言う時は言うんですよ
そんな調子で来るんだったら
海の向こうに捨ててやるぞと
まあまあ それはただのね
表現でね で 質問して まあ答えたりすると
で それで答えると もう本人がもうお釈迦様が言う命令はそのまま丸
守ることになっちゃうんですね
だから悟った人が支配者になるんですよ
もう逆はないんです 支配されることは不可能
支配してやるぞと思ったら
すぐ支配してるんですよ
断ると逆らうと これはできません
でも別に命令はしませんだけど
あまりにも断りたくてね
威張っていると 何のことなく淡々と奴隷化にして見せることだけは示します
ですから ここはもう欲の世界で欲を持ってる限りは奴隷なんですよ
欲はないと別に奴隷ではありません
誰にも だから悟ったらもう神にも遠慮はしない
もっと上の上のもう幽霊であろうか
これであろうか 何霊であろうか
もう全然もう気にしない
だから貪瞋痴があるとちょっと怯えがありますよね
こちらの神様は本当にご利益がいっぱいあって
私は節穴ことをしちゃうと
自分のご利益も収入もなくなるかもしれませんとかね
それがないんですね だから幽霊が脅してやる
はい どうぞと はい どうぞ
別にこちら怯えませんよ
だから貪瞋痴がないんだからね
こちら来て悟った人は別にもいろいろことをしてお前殺してやるぞとかね
舌を見せたり 目をこうやってとびやったり
面白い それで終わりというふうなことで
もう終わっちゃいますよ
もう嫌だとかね 殺されるぞとかね
それは欲がある時なんですよ
欲があると怯えちゃうし
だから別にお化けが来て舌を出す
そんなことなくても ちょっとささっと音だけ出ただけでも
もう足跡 あの 何と言いますか
廊下のね 聞いただけでも
もうみんなもうもう奴隷になってるんですよ
だから日本のね 廊下っていうのはあれだけ板だからね
音出すんですよ 夜になってくると寒くなってくると
チリチリチリチリと それでお化けが夜はいろいろね
物語まで作る 実はその旅館で
あのもう 年前だとかね
買っていた犬があって
それお客さんが間違ってあのもう外に出ようとところで倒れちゃって
犬の上で死んじゃって
犬の上に犬が潰れて死んじゃって
その犬がもう霊になって
そうやってもう夜チェチェって音出してるんですよ
くだらない話で インターネットでありますよ
日本人が喋ってる幽霊の話とかね
まとめて で まあ私は怪人だから今すぐ自分の国に帰りたいという
こういう人々と付き合ってなんすんね
それぐらい馬鹿げたくらいいい話もあるんですけど
まああのまあ楽しみでやるんだったらね
別にまあどうったことはないんですけど
真剣ではよくないと言いたいだけなんです
ただ馬鹿げてふざけて遊ぶんだったらね
まあそれはすごく明るくていいんですけどね
犬のしっぽ踏んだだけでしっぽだけの犬が家に出るんだとか
うん まあそういうふうな
あの そこでこの支配する支配されるという世界はそういうことで
貪瞋痴でなくなったら
その人が支配者なんです
っていうことは 支配したくて支配してるわけじゃなくて
誰にもあの征服することはできませんという意味なんです
誰にも命令することができません
誰にも誘惑することはできません
だからもうお手上げ 故に絶対的な支配者なんです
そういう意味で絶対的な支配者なんです
話聞いてないんだ 誰の話も聞かないんだから
誘惑されませんだから
悪い意味で支配者っていう意味じゃないんです
世界を征服して支配して威張ってるんだと
とんでもない話 それはもう頭の悪い世界で言ってることで
仏教でのそういうことじゃない
悪魔が来ようが 梵天が来ようが
帝釈天が来ようが 世界一べっぴんさんが来ようがあらゆる誘惑したっても
まあじゃあそれで終わったの？で終わっちゃいますよ
ご苦労様ですと 世界の美女たちがみんな来て
あらゆる誘惑しようと色々頑張ったら
終わったら大変ご苦労様でございましたと終わっちゃいますよ
だからもう支配者なんですね
踊りもとても美しかったよと
結構お稽古をなさったことでしょうねとかね
もう心配もしてあげる
支配者の心っていうのはそういうことなんですね
ですから そういう支配者なんですね
誘惑されないという定義で
ストーリーはない この前のストーリーとつなげています
こちらにつなげるべきストーリーはありますけど
このお釈迦様を誘惑しようと思って
マーラのね 世界からね
女神三人が来たんですけどね
で来て あらゆる工夫して踊ったりしてね
お釈迦様面白くないなというね
もう面白くないと言われるとね
これこそすごいね 例えばもう漫才の人がね
一生懸命漫才するとあとあくびでも行っちゃうと
もう終わりですよ 人生はもう
あの漫才師のね プロの人生っていうのはね
だから丁寧な人はいくら面白くないことであくびが出たっても
これはちょっとわからないようにしてあげる
そんなことで これは女神三人がもう踊りやら音楽にはもう神々だからね
まあ一番世界で一番上でしょうね
面白くないねということを
で 負けてすごく悲しくなっちゃって
落ち込んじゃって 父親にもね
父親と言ったっても この人間の世界とは父という意味じゃないんですよ
ただ たまたま神々の世界で
まあ遊びでね お前私の娘やとかね
そういうふうになるだけのことなんです
で 向こうもじゃあうちらは私のお父さんやとかね
そうやって遊んでるだけで
別に人間の世界みたいに親子関係とか DNA 関係とか全然ないんです
DNA はないんです ですからマーラの娘三人やとは言ってますけどね
まあお互いに仲良くしているグループでしょう
おそらくね まあ落ち込んじゃって
やっぱりもうブッダにはもういろいろいじめない方がいいということにもなってね
でもマーラはなかなか聞かないね
まだ時間足すとまだ一回やっちゃうって
何かやって またもう落ち込んじゃって
また忘れちゃうって また出てくるという
何回なんか そこでこのすごい欲にラティとかね
そういうものにお釈迦様誘惑しようとしたって
お釈迦様は全然まあ誘惑されなかった心の状態はね
それでやっぱり世界は何やっても私を誘惑することできんなと
できないねとかね なんか自分が今こそ本当の
何て言いますか 征服 勇者で
勇者で 全ての生命に打ち勝っているんだと
それは世俗世界では絶対ありえないんですよね
まあそういう状況を説明しています
心は毀損しない 誘惑しないと
うん  [背景音楽]